tu es prêt pour pour ces demi-finales
alors attends j'ai appris un truc hier
soir tu as remarqué qu'ils avaient des
écouteurs et des que les joueurs avaient
des écouteurs et des casques on en
reparlera un peu plus tard on demandera
la vie aux gens et apparemment d'après
ce que j'ai vu alors j'ai pas retrouvé
le passage exact mais apparemment les
joueurs sont obligés d'écouter de la
musique pendant qu'il lorsqu'il joue ben
moi je pense que c'est pas mal mais
faudrait que ce soit le choix de ton
adversaire est obligé d'écouter ce qu'il
veut que tu écoutes ouais alors ça c'est
c'est exact c'était une idée de Vlad en
plus à l'époque
très bonne idée alors moi j'étais étonné
dans le sens où les parties sont
homologuées et ça paraissait dans les
oreilles ouais ça me paraissait étonnant
et pour moi ça peut un peu expliquer le
tilt un peu de Doha ou quoi quand tu
écoutes de la musique tu es un peu donc
tu vois je reviendrai un peu sur ce que
j'ai dit sur sur Jean-Christophe j'étais
pas au courant du du truc en fait non
bah c'est spécial enfin te faire un
tournoi officiel ou tu es obligé
d'écouter de la musique tu leur mets un
casque qui coupe le bruit et puis c'est
tout on t'oblige à écouter de la musique
pendant pendant les parties donc je mets
bien avancé comme ça enfin voilà c'est
une nouveauté ça n'a jamais existé c'est
une information que j'ai chiné mais j'ai
pas j'ai pas retrouvé l'extrait ils en
parlent ils parlent d'une interview à
Nakamura on parle euh mais alors est-ce
que tu as le droit est-ce que tu écoutes
vraiment ce que tu veux est-ce que tu as
le droit de tu vois non mais j'avais vu
un tweet de toute façon de chaise comme
qui disait à votre avis qu'est-ce qui
coûte Naka avec une vidéo ou pas tête
donc c'est peut-être juste c'était
vraiment premier degré tu vois mais je
crois ouais
mais c'est pas qu'on avait forcé c'est
qu'il y avait une une techno parade à
côté ou une je sais pas quoi et des
chars qui passaient et tout et ça
faisait trembler les vitres il y a du
son à fond et ça s'est arrêté bon ben
j'étais très bien je m'en foutais en
fait mais votre adversaire il était pas
bien quoi ah là tu choisis ta musique
Rammstein dans les oreilles tiens
bah écoute on va un peu regarder leur
partie en attendant l'autre enfin je
suis un petit peu étonné regardons si si
ça se fait arnaquer ou pas et du coup
ils ont carrément changé les câbles des
caméras de joueurs ouais c'est tu sais
pas qui va jouer quand ou il y a des
petits des petits travelcam là toi tu
vois pas ouais c'est magnifique là ce
qui est en train de faire
le ouais ouais c'est beau on a vu un
geste technique du du caméraman Fabien
assez exceptionnel
il a fait quoi une il a fait des petits
tours il a fait des petits aller-retours
tu sais un peu comme dans le sketch des
Inconnus Power Rangers
c'était assez réussi nous sommes les
gentils on doit pas trop les méchants
parce que je ne devant marron derrière
exactement bah écoute c'est pas
d'ailleurs pour gagner ils envoient le
disque de Dorothée c'est vrai en plus
bah allez pas du tout avec des armes
normales tiens écoute ça et là il serait
très fort aux échecs dans les conditions
des règles qu'on va mettre quoi
marrant cette règle de musique j'ai
vraiment cherché comme ça me paraît
tellement lunaire que je suis vraiment
allé chercher et tout j'ai pas réussi à
trouver l'extrait mais bon le truc c'est
que sur le poste que j'ai lu tu as
personne qui disait tu vois en mode
non arrête de raconter n'importe quoi
genre les mecs qui discutaient quoi
faire qu'est-ce que tu en penses
qu'est-ce qu'il écoute
en F5 non il va juste se faire voir le
roi Niall Sarine ça peut ça peut bon F5
il faut réfléchir enfin F5 qui est
dessiné attends il y a Wesley qui arrive
il est en train de mettre la musique sur
ses oreilles Naka qui sourit qui met le
casque elle va peut-être faire F5 qui va
aller 5 francs aussi 7
6e et tu fais retourner un et qu'il y
avait trois cahiers des quatre enfin tu
peux quand même tourner tu as des cases
aussi pour toi
donc
ouais je pensais il se mette club pour
pour
moi on a parlé sur son stream après
c'est game avant-hier il disait qu'ils
étaient obligés oui bah enfin il a bien
confirmé écouter club je suis quand même
hyper étonné que le que le tournoi soit
homologué fidèle franchement bah il y a
beaucoup de choses qui font ces chelou
non mais là la musique obligatoire enfin
c'est ah bah disons la musique c'est le
dernier truc
le cerise quoi
c'est la belle cerise c'est pas la
petite souris
alors que le tournoi soit comme ça que
ce soit ses règles ça ça ne me dérange
absolument pas c'est organisé un tournoi
tu fais absolument ce que tu veux après
que la fille homologue ça comme
condition de jeu normal pour que ça
compte pour le vélo bah je sais pas
c'est à dire que c'est les deux mains tu
fais un truc tu as quelqu'un qui fait de
la tronçonneuse à côté de toi et ça va
être un standard normal de de tournoi de
l'histoire d'ailleurs obligatoire là
c'est obligatoire
là en fait je sais pas si jamais tu es
dans un endroit et puis il se trouve que
dans la salle à côté il y a un concert
et que tu entends un peu du bruit bon
bah t'as rien demandé mais on sait comme
ça mais là en fait tu es obligé le
concert à côté quoi limite j'aurais pas
trop on verra pas de concert ouais c'est
ça c'est très étonnant c'est spécial
donc il y a pas d'énormes flaque d'eau
sur le terrain de foot on jouera pas
ouais c'est pas que tu l'autorises c'est
que tu l'obliges
je trouve ça extrêmement étonnant que ça
joue une énième espagnol
ouais donc la fameuse anti berlinoise
avec cette version moderne avec des
seins rapides le Doodle
alors bon il y avait eu pas tout à fait
ça
c'était pas très bien passé pour
Jean-Christophe très très bien donc ceux
qui changent pour liquider la tension au
centre après
on va te dire c'est léger léger plus
pour les blancs mais bon trois fois rien
ça vient juste que tu es plus content
d'avoir
le cayans des deux que le client C6
alors que le cahier 2 bah il va pouvoir
aller verser 4 ou vers F1 G3 voilà bon
c'est bon tu vois c'est assez
léger comme avantage je te rassure tous
les gens du chat bon c'est égal en fait
là ça changerait pas grand chose
pourtant mais là il nous manque la barre
là enfin en même temps je commande
ça je peux vraiment le dire
a été plus à l'aise là
je m'étais un peu des pincettes dans ce
que je disais les gens vont mieux voilà
il a quand même la barre la 25 je le
vois
elle reste quand même un peu à
l'intérieur du 5 si j'avais le pouvoir
d'achat
S
[Musique]
avec fil il a les
autres que je suis là enfin il est très
bien quoi
il pourra placer la coquette somme de
100000 euros quoi
à l'excellento 2-4%
ce serait beau en fait tu le tournoi en
écoutant ça tu es très heureux quoi il a
fait B6 ma coutivos se replacer c'est
plutôt bien joué de la part de wesleo
c'est bizarre des fois en fait j'arrive
à être focus à plus trop écouter ce qui
se passe autour mais moi pour le coup
vous faites chaque fois je suis sur
Internet j'en écoute quasiment mais bon
tu vois enfin je prends pas ça super au
sérieux quoi
si je fais un tournoi normal c'est vrai
même pas idée quoi
la chanson dimanche par exemple c'est
pas mal mais je pense que pour c'est en
blitz ça va mais je pense qu'en rapide
comme je te dis plus de temps ça aurait
trop envie de faire
un peu quoi tu étais bien quand même en
fait tu es heureux d'écouter ça non ok
il prend le 4 c'était pas terrible parce
que les Blancs défendent deux fois le
pion attention voilà même trois fois
maintenant eh tu peux le rattaquer une
troisième fois aussi pour lui dire moi
aussi j'attaque
mais bon pas génial enfin on voit le
fouet fin qui tire la gueule quoi il y a
beaucoup de pions sur sa couleur le pion
à 4 ça peut être une cible contrairement
au pion à 5 qui est bien soutenu avec la
chaîne de pions donc plutôt mieux il y a
des cases un peu faibles sur case noir
aussi de l'autre côté après un cavalier
5 pour arriver donc ouais écoute et ko
un peu en danger plutôt moins bien de
démarrer ton match comme ça bon après il
y a quand même 8 parties tu as le temps
de de remonter même si super de ça bah
si en fait il est mieux parce que il
peut contourner faire des choses
notamment ben c'est en Russie imagine tu
arrives un peu les pièces dans la finale
tu vas l'attaquer les pions adverse
alors que le fouet fin il est en mode
plot alors il peut défendre ses pions
j'insiste à la place de la dame mais
c'est tout il aura que un rôle défensif
au mieux mais
on imagine mal devenir intéressant alors
la finale cavalier contre fou elle
serait vraiment bien pour les Noirs si
je vais pas remplacer 5 contre le fouet
fin alors que si tu joues un cavalier B3
contre un fou B7 c'est quand même les
noirs qui sont mieux
quatre ouais ça gagne un pion mais pas
pour longtemps qu'elle prend à 5 dessus
donc ils se venge et en fait tu changes
un pion de toi qui était pas faible donc
il y en a 5 ou le 4 qui restera une
cible long terme donc c'est pas un
échange dans l'intérêt des Noirs tout
une amélioration pour les blancs la
disparition de ses pions mieux vaut ne
pas le faire par contre tu as vu un
article de l'équipe aujourd'hui Damien
penaud enfin je sais qui joue hein je
vais déjà parler qui dit que ça a
beaucoup qui a la progressé au rugby les
échecs en fait c'est beau les échecs
c'est bien pour tout sauf pour les
échecs
[Musique]
pas si étonnant au contact des salles
battles
[Musique]
après c'est juste à haute dose que tu
vois enfin on a trop d'exemples on se
dit qu'en fait c'est nocif quoi mais
la petite dose c'est sûr ça des vertus
et que ça joue plaisant quoi qu'il en
soit ils disent Nadal était 2080 à ce
moment là
à passer deux tours au Madrid
il pleutre donc il peut rien lui arriver
mais je vois pas comment il va créer une
menace
après peut la jouer longtemps oui
donc Fab ça a repris un peu en avance
cette fois-ci mais c'est guérissant
[Musique]
moins fort après bon écoute une
opposition de style et ce qui va arriver
à l'arnaquer ou pas bon dans la première
non mais il y a cette partie c'était
quoi c'est une slave une femme une
Antigone
on va voir bon ça s'invite enfin disons
ça doit être encore théorique
en plus peut-être
ou même en rapide d'habitude je pense
rapide il est très très bon
spécialiste internet joueur spécialisé
du coup il est extrêmement dangereux bon
dans le sens opposition de style pour
répondre à la galette c'est que fait
guéri est plus fort a priori
c'était un peu comme séviant qui avait
complètement dominé le match contre
Sarine dans le jeu il est souvent
l'avantage et il concluait jamais
et donc je pense ça aux positions de
style parce que guéri on imaginait
qu'elle avait un peu le scénario donc
mieux jouer être bien mais est-ce que
lui il allait arriver à conclure ou se
prendre des pots de banane ou les éviter
voilà ça va jouer à ça au réalisme en
fait ça dépend des conditions de fin ça
dépend de beaucoup de choses là dans ces
conditions là je le sens moins favori
qu'on te guéri mais après c'est du 55
ans il venait d'avoir 18 ans c'est ça
dans la chanson
pas si sûr parce que ça fait quand même
longtemps qu'il est là comme c'est comme
ils font beaucoup beaucoup d'échecs
quand ils sont jeunes ils ont parfois
moins de marge de progression que que
d'autres joueurs plus à aller chercher
encore je suis en train de voir qu'il y
a Valère rot qui vient de tweet alors il
a vu l'ouverture de Baki ouais et en
fait il te dit c'est trop subtil pour
moi
j'aime bien les subtilités dans les
ouvertures mais celle là est trop
profonde pour moi vraiment
je suis en capacité de comprendre quoi
je crois qu'il faudra qu'il regarde
simply backy hein je vais lui écrire bon
j'ai une tentative d'explication et
alors c'est fort par contre là tu
demandes beaucoup mais qu'en gros sur H3
les Noirs ils ont bah genre un coup
logique c'est cavalier F6 et il veut
jouer fou des trois donc à priori il
aurait joué fou des trois sur cabalifi
au lieu de A6
[Musique]
partir en E7 mais déjà télé une fois 7
etc donc tu dois éliminer des lignes tu
rends l'autre normal qualifi c'est pas
forcément génial tu fais tu fais je veux
une structure au noir et mais voilà ça
va être un coup pour jouer donc je pense
pas que ça affute la ligne en toi mais
il y a des idées ok
tu auras sûrement plus que ce que je te
dis là mais c'est ce que je peux en
comprendre rapidement comme ça il faut
faire tout à 7 sur KFC 7 c'est ça on
voit la jauge qui monte de toute façon
sur la jauge aussi peut-être que ici
cette trop ci sans battement et c'est ça
toi c'est 6 ça va te faire un petit peu
mal hein
belle réaction et Naka c'est pas parti
je pensais partir peut-être on regarde
jusqu'à la fin ça là on ira après
ok j'ai cette jouée tour à 7 et donc on
se donne à Tours
C8
mais
ça c'est très joli
en fait
c'est beau ça
je me serais dit t'en prends B6 cool si
je veux prendre en SESSAD je prends deux
fois je mets les deux tours sur la 8e
j'ai gagné
enfin en fait non après en partie longue
j'aurais probablement vu qu'il est 7
mais en blitz je me serais arrêté là
mais bon ça relance le match
immédiatement enfin bon attends faut
encore conclure mais bon ça a l'air
assez simple quand même on est assez
conscient pour le genre indien mais qui
sait
dire qu'il y a un truc marrant sur tour
des 7 enfin un moment donné si tu veux
te déclouer tu as toujours les trucs
comme ça ou tu savais ça que quand tu as
un double clouage
tu te barres tu te barres en fait c'est
les trucs sont pas protégés ah tu manges
tu manges
je sais pas si je savais mais je veux
dire que ça marche toujours enfin ça
marche
du coup je m'en vais je te bouffe de
l'autre côté je me suis déjà pris
plusieurs fois ça m'a saoulé maintenant
j'ai remarqué ça marche souvent ce truc
là genre tu fais le cloche que dans un
sens mais tu sais que double cloison
jamais qu'il prend à 6 ça va marcher en
fait
c'est chiant hein
double prise ça je me suis déjà pris
genre tu es là tu es très heureux tu dis
oui il est cloué mon jeu encore de
l'autre côté là il pourra vraiment plus
jamais bouger ah merde il part
en plus
il a commencé par JK
pourquoi pas en même temps
il s'est un peu mis aux échecs du genre
2004 non et genre 2004 bon c'est parce
que le fait le jeu est très simple pour
lui alors que les meilleurs joueurs
d'échec qui se mettent au shoguy bon tu
te prends des tactiques tout le temps
partout tu vois rien tu es en vrai
c'était biberonné au Shogi tu passes aux
échecs à 14-15 ans peut-être que tu es
juste hyper fort en fait c'est
un peu les deux tu apprends un peu la
stratégie aux échecs
[Musique]
jamais de tactique tu t'en fous tu fais
ta tactique à ton autre jeu et après tu
tiens viens calculer un peu ça mais tu
sais j'avais lu un truc qui disait que
si tu étais sur une si tu né dans une
planète où les joueurs ils jouaient les
meilleurs joueurs du monde était tout ça
3500 hello que en fait il finit tu
aurais plus de chance de jouer à 3500
enfin je sais plus j'avais lu un truc
comme ça mais je sais plus comment
c'était formulé exactement mais dans
l'idée en fait tu serais tiré vers le
haut en fait
du niveau des autres et tu aurais
beaucoup plus de chance de t'en
approcher je sais pas quel point c'est
vrai
tu es peut-être parti faire un match
d'échec shurik en du moins chogui ouais
ouais
il a perdu j'imagine ouais mais je pense
que le mec aux échecs auraient des
chances de lui prendre une nul alors que
lui le shoguy il prendrait 1000 zéro
quoi alors pour calculer aux échecs
déjà que c'était pas si clair en fait
c'est ça me fait un peu penser à Dragon
Ball en fait Maxime c'est un genre de
Krilin pour eux quoi
du sel c'est un peu du vagin bon bah
je pense qu'il est très fort pour des
lambdas
Simon ils sont disques ouais c'est ça
max
de Dragon Ball Fab bah j'aime bien son
Goku mais c'était pas le meilleur tu
vois peut-être que Vegeta il est plus
perso préféré quoi
j'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi Gohan
tout d'un coup il a décidé d'être
chercheur en fait bah oui il y a des
prometteurs et puis ça faisait sa
carrière de combattant quoi il fait il
fait que de la merde après je crois
pourquoi tu cherches juste tape sur la
gueule des autres enfin jamais trop
compris en fait
ok bon bah égalisation
[Musique]
pendant un mois
comme ça et c'est très chiant les pions
ce qu'ils avancent tout droit ouais mais
j'ai aussi non ouais mais aux échecs ils
mangent le côté quoi là ils savent
je te prends quoi mais après c'est pas
très grave ce que tu peux pas reposer un
pion sur une colonne tu as déjà un pion
tu peux pas avoir de deux pions sur la
même colonne donc en fait si tu gagnes
un pion et puis tu as tout tes pions tu
peux pas le poser en fait ah faut que tu
l'as vraiment gagner
mais tu peux pas l'utiliser quoi
il met l'autre la plus ouais mais il va
te le bouffer avec d'autres pièces c'est
assez faible pion ça avance que d'une
case quoi après ah bah tu peux le
retourner ouais enfin tu l'as pris genre
il est dans ta main après tu le reposes
on était aux échecs normaux
je te prends un fou et après je me le
repose j'aurai trois fous et toi seul
exactement ah bah voilà une petite nulle
magnifique
on va je l'aimais pas en caméra parce
que ça on va regarder l'autre partie
mais elle s'est garé avec les Blancs
gros problème
ils se font un match thématique il s'en
foutent quand
c'est un peu changé il a fait un peu
prendre des cinq qui avaient pas fait
dans l'autre partie les jeux qui est BD
plutôt
donc changement de structure Camille BO5
est deux jours de suite dans ses bo4 de
jour de suite enfin c'est bo8 et c'est
deux fois quatre parties voilà c'est
assez égal de nouveau vous voyez la
jauge il se passe absolument rien dans
cette partie nouvelle fois mais on se
fait kiffer
muscle ton jeu Robert muscle ton jeu et
magnifique cette vidéo encore une drôle
voilà partie là elle était
insipide
tu fais rien tu fais rien tu attends
qu'une minute chacun et tu cliques comme
un comme un con pour gagner en 200 coups
mais bon les échecs
game of the chasse game important
toujours parler anglais Fab dans les
commentaires
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible il
l'a raté
gagne la prochaine vous allez en train
de lipider
[Musique]
cirque la partie de Baki que j'ai mis en
rediffus j'ai mis une rediff et
incroyable quoi la partie la plus
chiante de l'année
et c'est exception c'est une slave
d'échange box il joue une petite
variante il se retrouve avec l'option a
en plus ils font nul dans une finale
immonde
partie dure 7 minutes c'est de la merde
il se passe rien
et c'est beau est-ce que les gens ont
cliqué en masse sur la vidéo c'est
vidéo très regardé c'est une partie de
merde
pensez une pause Express on revient dans
10 minutes
mais ça va ressembler très portrait à ce
qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent est-ce qu'on
va suivre le speed chasse ben
bizarrement dans le speechestre ça reste
de toutes les compétitions internet
celle que je préfère
j'avais bien aimé la première édition
d'ailleurs tout le monde avait aimé
après petit à petit like et quand même
retombé sur cette compète pour
multaraison on va dire que c'est la de
toutes les compétitions existantes sur
Internet c'est la seule où il y a des
matchs ça me fait vraiment plaisir de
les voir
tu vois l'an dernier
[Musique]
parce que c'était de 1h à 4h du mat et
moi il se trouve que je dormais pas et
j'ai carrément regardé la fin parce que
il y avait un point d'écart que c'était
chaud donc fait ok tu vois pour que je
regarde une compétition d'échec quand je
commande pas enfin
plus à 4h du mat quoi encore plus à 4h
du mat mais là je te jure je vais me
coucher à minuit 23h20 et je regarde il
y a d'ink qui mène d'un point puis c'est
chaud puis il est parti son cool
je me suis regardé je me suis retrouvé à
regarder mais tu vois enfin genre pour
que je me retrouve à regarder un truc
d'échec c'est le match de Maxime il
était sympa la finale contre so c'était
aussi sympa même si ce soit pas réussi à
mettre en danger fin non mais c'est
très très franchement de tous les trucs
internet c'est le c'est le meilleur et
c'est tellement dommage que ils avaient
pas pris ce speech qui est bien et
qu'ils aient 1000 et 1 million de
dollars tu as un truc qui est peut être
pas mal machin et tout et c'est bizarre
d'avoir pris un autre format c'est quoi
en fait non mais en plus le speech si
jamais tu veux vraiment faire comme là
leur truc à Toronto quoi tu le fais
ensuite mais c'est vrai tu es mille fois
mieux
c'est à dire que tu fais les phases
machin et puis peut-être tu dis ok les
quatre derniers vas-y on se fait le
week-end final on va à Toronto ou tu
veux en fait Toronto ou pas
dans une belle salle comme ça tu fais le
truc et puis un match et puis l'autre
après j'ai fait en même temps évidemment
et la grande finale le dimanche et puis
c'est bon c'est fini non mais moi
j'aurais fait j'aurais fait encore
différemment enfin dans la même idée que
toi mais peut-être encore mieux je les
aurais pris peut-être même sur deux
weekends tellement il y a d'argent tu
peux leur dire de rester et en fait j'en
aurais fait jouer aucun sur Internet
c'est en fait tu étais tout sur
invitation tant pis en fait enfin c'est
pas grave et tu joues tout en réel et je
te mets pas d'inviter enfin je te mets
pas de qualification sur internet en
fait là ah tiens c'est pas de chance en
fait mais tu pourras pas en fait et au
moins bah j'ai un fil de Clean je te
prends les lots en blitz enfin je sais
pas je te fais un mélange et je te fais
ça mais fin je récupère un peu ce que tu
disais quoi mais juge enlève la face
calife internet je m'en fous c'est
étonnant en fait qu'ils aient pas fait
ça parce qu'ils tiennent un format qui
est pas mal que les gens aiment bien les
joueurs aiment bien et même tu vois j'en
disc Richard et tout de ce speechs et ça
reste un truc que les gens aiment bien
quand même ce speechs étonnamment dans
les compétitions internet c'est un peu
la dernière qui garde un petit
prestigeonner tu vois
je sais pas c'est un peu le Grand Slam
d'internet je sais pas comment dire
c'est beau en fait c'est ça c'est en
fait à tous les tons internet qui sont
là qui sont venus bon ils mettent des
millions de tout bon oui bon bravo enfin
tu as gagné bon on s'en fout et là le
speechers ah non en fait ah tiens c'est
un truc un peu historique quoi il y a
une il y a il y a un prestige
qui s'est fait au cours des saisons et
c'est dommage de pas avoir mis le paquet
sur ce truc là qui est bien non mais
après juste il faut qu'il modifie un
truc ou deux c'est quand il y a un
carnage dans le match qui s'arrête vous
qui fasse un système de 7 ou que oui
mais c'est juste ça c'est pas grand
chose en fait c'est très facile à gérer
ça mais tu as pas envie de voir un 25 un
encore une fois ou moi un truc pas mal
je lavais dit de enfin c'était con comme
idée mais j'avais proposé parce que ça
pouvait changer les temps d'audience
donc pour les pubs bon attention
j'aurais dit en fait à tout moment dans
le match tu mets 6-0 ou 5-0 bon a décidé
c'est un carreau et tu as gagné
non en fait je disais ok au fait même si
tu es mené 8 à 1
bon en fait le match
c'est un KO tu as gagné le match
bon c'est très improbable à un moment
donné même si tu arrives au but en
belette avec 10 points de moins tu en
gagnes deux daffilée bon de l'autre
comment ça suit un peu
c'est un petit ajout complètement débile
mais là il avait envoyé
[Musique]
dessus et au moins les blancs faut pas
prendre de gel celle qui va aller en
l'air mais tout reprend et ta page est 5
parce que Kylie F5 attaque la dame et tu
fais des trous partout et du coup il va
s'ouvrir la colonel doubler les tours
etc quoi qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
mais en fait c'est pas si clair parce
que si on prend il veut pas qu'il prend
des quatre il touche là quand même bah
si il veut ça et puis on prend
du pion F4 et ok parce qu'en fait sur
tout reprendre
il repart vers eux
c'est pas mal son cou en fait aussi il
faut dire
avoir
genre FG qui est des 4
GH3 je pense
des pions
complètement par hasard avec Mathieu un
truc un peu similaire
dans une vidéo qu'on faisait et il se
trouve qu'on avait conclu bah c'est avec
deux tours contre deux tours cavaliers
et cette structure enfin c'était pas la
même structure
et on en avait conclu que c'était égal
fait les trois pions sont aussi fort que
le cavalier alors après c'était pas la
même structure à la dame et puis ça joue
sur des détails
mais c'était une partie un peu bizarre
qu'on avait regardé et comme il y avait
une nouveauté théorique Mathieu avait
poussé à fond et en fait
tu avais un truc comme juste c'est
similaire sauf que tu as les pions je
sais pas à cette B7 C6 c'est A4 B2A C2
enfin je sais pas exactement mais juste
les pions qui ont pas trop bouger Elda
mais il se trouve que fait du cavalier
trouve pas vraiment des cases et puis
avant c'est vraiment double tranchant
comment je fais en brigader là non mais
en fait des fois je fais un brigader
dans les vidéos avec Mathieu parce que
c'est terrible si on fait des vidéos le
matin bon évidemment bon pour la théorie
le machin et tout je m'en fous on fait
enfin je m'en fous complètement mais il
me montre à fond alors après ça me sert
donc du coup il doit se dire j'ai
vraiment bien fait de lui montrer
vraiment très utile mais tu vois il a
pas ouais mais il fallait en plus je
pense qu'on en parle dans la vidéo de la
variante nakan n'a jamais su en fait
ouais mais faut travailler avec Mathieu
mais il va peut-être pas gagné donc en
fait ce match on rigole on rigole mais
là il est pas très bien quand même enfin
il a juste une qualité de moi
[Musique]
quand même le Chat en pleine forme
donc ça va
à 6
voilà mais dans l'autre partie ça joue
encore par curiosité
tu bloques
mais je sais pas ça se trouve ça parce
que
F5
j'ai compris mais trop tard aussi je me
serais fait avoir enfin il va tomber
comme on a dit arnaque c'est bien ce
qu'on avait dit au début de ce match Fab
OK et juste tu peux revenir enfin pour
nous curiosité à nous quoi du coup ce
qu'il fallait faire pour gagner
ou pour voilà
[Musique]
et juste avant et là tu progresses
comment enfin je comprends que tu es
gagnant mais voilà tu fais ça
on fait repartir
qu'il a gagné ça non c'est pas sûr du
tout
[Musique]
six top intéressant avec le cavalier
placé comme ça qui te bloque bien
il va peut-être même la perdre en fait
pas jusque là
tu dois pas prendre
il va essayer de te répéter les coups
[Musique]
c'est un truc gluant quoi ça te glisse
entre les mains c'est horrible les
longues
faire G4 et de m'énerver mais bon après
comme ça que je suis toujours par perdre
en fait je m'énerve et on va faire un
truc comme toi FC histoire des 6 vas-y
on va te filer un pion et je vais
pouvoir ta tour là-bas qui m'emmerde
trois pions le titre de la vidéo c'était
guéri et sipianko la partie tu vois et
bien russe
tu vois ça fait une autre association
je pète un câble
et que il pense que les blancs sont
mieux mais enfin je pense pas lui il
pense ouais
c'est terrible c'est dégueulasse en fait
non mais c'est des fois c'est
dégueulasse
il va falloir c'est horrible c'est
horrible j'aurais tellement en tilte
tout soit bouffer
c'est fini
en fait non mais le truc c'est quand il
se prend F4 et tout ça il est juste mal
mais ça doit pas tourner enfin c'est pas
normal que ce soit la résultante de ce
truc là ce sont un truc si complexe
[Musique]
un des plus grands défenseurs de
l'histoire des échecs hikaro tu prends
tu fais nul
mais si tu prends c'est juste une
vachement tu dois prendre en fait
de sa partie ou dégoûté de pas avoir pu
gagner parce qu'il avait sentir qu'il
était pas loin quoi ah bah oui
franchement
faire tourner ça terrible dans tous les
matchs enfin ouais ben écoute c'est très
serré en vrai les parties tu es plus
sympa aujourd'hui bon allez bon on fait
le petit renne merci à toi mon Fab on se
retrouve demain on va dire let's go ça
marche